i ragazzi siamo tornati supera di 13
questa volta in compagnia di anima è
successa una cosa incredibile che avrete
già letto dal titolo ma sti cazzi il
video è una bomba tutto quanto ma il
pezzo finale dove succede la roba epica
parte dalla battaglia numero 3 quindi
dal tipo tre minuti poi quindi se volete
saltate direttamente l'italia ma
guardatevi tutto il video che fa
scattare comunque fino a vito 696 membro
stephanie mack l'ora anch'io afferma
sempre gemelli ma perché da troppo nette
accendi la in flash led e la spara flash
davanti a tutti popolo cabin ok perfetto
ma tu hai meglio che non sai quindi come
si gioca i tasti che direi di no ma io
mi chiedo nell'armadio che non era mario
spiega l'agente lo aspetta con ciò che
come riporta le porte a jason sparare
bordate che sei vicina ma ancora qua
porca eva che cagà che bella roba che ho
visto vabbè comunque sta arrivando jazz
di porco ci siamo ma la di qua ce l'ha
fatta
ciao fascia o le altre faccio lascia
stare il mio amico lo schalke non si fa
così non ti invitiamo più ai no siamo
durati sei secondi però è stato bello
test tra yemen e stato ben la destra
prima partita diciamo che adatta bene e
stato bellissimo dei pro gamer
se tu metti già lo è ma vieni vieni
sente in casa troviamo questa chiusura
tecnico di aprire open o per we have and
italian wave berlusconi craxi adesso
incazza sì che c'è qualcosina troy
aspetta che era uscita ed ha d'altra
parte aveva una certa si entra si entra
l'acqua poi vedere come si scavalca è
questa se no
ataf ok perfetto fammi chiudere la
finestra ha trovato una chiave per
qualcosa che sveglia mister un test oggi
occhio chiuso ma dov'è ma chi cazzo sono
questi ma state lavate via
bene anche in casa gesù addio st sponde
a napoli e vestito tutto ma che vestito
a ma come si veste ios non scappava
perché cesta musica di merda aiuto mi
sta ricorrendo ma che ti sta rincorrendo
sto tornando da te è il trace la
finestra spezzata detto a destra e se la
mia trotta dove casa
[Musica]
ma porca vacca sono entrato io non so
come lazio gioca così io vedendo cosa
sta venendo occhio ai affittato a cazzo
no eh vabbè miglia quanto quanto ha
fatto gli effetti sonori questione qual
è il tasto per parlare
layla l'addio la ypsilon migliore non è
scritta haier ha preso giornate regali
[Musica]
ai un rapporto che bello sono jason
veramente assolutamente no però sofferto
vincere una macchina qui la macchina
ricchi ok chiede la chiave che la
benemerita bezier avresti trovare forse
sul molo io che non avevo visto che ci
ho trovato la batteria
veramente io sono venuto dalla tua parte
io adesso video è mangiandone 44 a
distrarlo dai a testa ragazzo a me ga ga
nicchia che porta in faccia gli ha dato
daniela casalvieri primavera i corni
corro si corre corre tanto la è fermo
jason non so perché è rimasto stordito
vieni nella casa veri prima allora vieni
e seguimi
a parte non entro in casa dalla
seguibili qua dobbiamo superare lago ok
io sono batterie ma guarda secondo me sì
minchia per quello che stiamo facendo
però non va bene
diamo batteria ma in mare ma sia
immediata come siamo stealth
ok la macchina equa perfetto il problema
anche a benzina e chiavi e va beh
intanto abbiamo stata magari hanno messo
già qualcos'altro i ragazzi non hanno
messo new york i colori che cosa fa mina
è peccato che non c'è la barca bisogna
possiamo aprire la benzina vedo se ce le
chiavi dove possono essere secondo tempo
nei cassetti
io lo sento lo senti è che erano in casi
di casa in casa in casa ancora lo vedono
entrato mai lo stanno comprando nota e
lo hanno picchiato sono ritardo abbiamo
la vita cosa dobbiamo a cosa vogliamo e
cosa più alla chiesa piena padella lo so
ha detto lo zio mi chiamo la batteria la
batteria e accame johnston motivo
picchiato che non sto mettendo la
batteria mentre voi combattete oddio è
rimasto fermo che cazzo è successo a
tempo che ti sta picchiando vai al
ginocchio
[Musica]
ma questa voce da carlin ha esplicitato
batteria m padrino grassa facendo a iaia
buttan animale sarebbe chiamato lo
stesso lo stesso di questo visto non sto
mettendo la batteria ragazze oggi è
ovvio che se si incazza sicilia occhio
baby alla miele via via via via via via
che via via di chi ti sta peccando bravo
mica sempre gas cento il caso ma dove
sei
entra quanto non ha senso questo giorgio
allora vado a cercare se c'è roba per
okaka
io ripeto sopra e mi sono chiusa un
piano sopra ai anche se mi trova mi
suicido tenendo in casa viola ma possa
suicidarsi passo ciao sono suicidato va
bene l'importante è non essere preso da
gesù sui side manchi tu sei solo più
vivo però io sì veramente sì se per caso
vedi che sei alle strette prova
ucciderlo tanto ormai ma secondo te è
ormai avrà poca vita occhio che guarda
per terra vedi che c'è uno spray cosa
serve per curarti teso io mi sono curato
mi sono curato bene bene è la rai fuori
fuori occhio maio t'ammazzo sai che
perde per un attimo ci ho creduto
veramente
oddio oddio derivato ti sei liberato sul
serio una battaglia all'ultimo sangue
rai
no no no non riprenderanno il milan per
cavani ma io sono donna lire capitolo si
fosse corretto marco a destra mare
io faccio adesso oddio ma se cazzuta se
vuoi mi allarma e buttano giù è l'unica
che qualcosa che puoi fare ancora e
tentare di ucciderlo provava cd no
dall'altra parte
picchia picchia lo sa lui non ha la
malaria casacca bravo sei una merda
tanto forte più provare ad ucciderlo ed
un reporter l'arma però ma equa
colpiscilo
[Musica]
madonna che possa questo il dato del
senato che sta dormendo gol così è
rimasto così dura e scemo è diventato
scemo io ma da un uomo stata la testa ha
detto no non ci posso credere
oddio andata sotto nel lago io si
suicida un omaggio a chi cazzo è
veramente successo quello che ho appena
visto che cazzo successo perché ma come
ha fatto scappata la mano a parma lazio
sono più perplesso di te la prima volta
che due si fotte col getto
non ho parole come è possibile ma lo
ripara la macchina così forte che la
ripara bastonate
oddio non ci posso credere che sia
successo perché hai vinto sei riuscito a
vincere hai fatto tra il calciatore non
assumere una più vita però non li metto
l'animazione che muore mentre solo
aggressore che scappa quindi noi
praticamente ucciso tipo torna a casa
non lo so non lo so sinceramente hai
ucciso jason chen direttore conto non ci
consentono rende possibile una parola
che cattura ma non ci posso credere
ragazzi e 4 c dirigendo non lo so è
stato superbo la ragazza ento via lycans
a ci ha fatto il miracolo non si sa come
cazzo sia possibile ma ti rendi conto
che sono scappato tre volte da lui e
sacri che non la battaglia finale stato
incredibile bravo sasso voglio una fetta
di torta della votate la preparo io no
ma veramente non ci possiamo credere
assurdo io direi che è
dopo questa vittoria di sasha
inaspettata ma che è possibile non si va
beh va beh direi che possiamo chiudere
qui episodio ringrazio sasha per aver
fatto il culo accesso anche se potevi
salvarmi la vita quindi ragazzi quando
vi sia piaciuto con quello che
l'episodio era una sorta di sacra in
descrizione cosa secondo me non mi piace
chi non lascia mi piace jason è una
canzone altro che sul fronte sindacale
ci vediamo al prossimo vita dalla
gabella
[Musica]